all right one more this one is a man I
couldn't even I don't even know if this
is even real my 23 year old male
girlfriend 25 year old female of 8
months her birthday present was a butt
plug as a butt plug for the 6th time and
told me to stop [ __ ] farting
always I can keep reading this one okay
of eight months birthday present to me
was a tattoo of my name and face on her
back I don't really know what to say
here but I'll try my best
I've been together I can't read this can
you can you man plus it a little bit
[ __ ] dumb blind [ __ ] I've been
together with my gf for a little over
eight months now we don't live together
but she only lives about a five-minute
walk from me so this is 8 months I would
have described the relationship before
this week it's pretty slow neither of us
really wanted any big commitments yet so
outside of date nights Netflix and
occasional hookups the relationship has
been pretty laid-back
that was until last weekend my birthday
was Saturday and my brother came to town
and we were gonna have a small party I
invited Kim obviously and she seemed
really excited she claims she had spent
over a month thinking about what to give
me after I supervised her with a pretty
expensive present for her birthday I
should wait surprised her what did I say
supervised supervised he wrote
supervised yeah I should have picked up
something I supervised her I should have
picked up something was off here when
she avoided seeing me face to face for
about a week before the party but I put
it but I put it down to other things
well Saturday comes and we were having a
big party of about nine people
Kim Kim made a big show about getting
everyone together because she wanted to
give me her present in front of everyone
well this is where things got crazy for
my birthday present Kim got a massive
tattoo on her back of my face underneath
my face there is text saying mine
forever this has to be fake this can't
be real silence was deafening it didn't
help that the tattoo was not even half
done oh my god me and her have been
fighting non-stop since then too
is claiming that I completely
disrespected her in front of everyone
and is now saying I'm some [ __ ] boy who
oh oh my god
I mean this chick is batshit insane oh I
love this top comment first of all that
even a present first off that's not a
present yeah yeah first of all before
any of this [ __ ] that no present that's
not a present that's that's a that's not
like you've been yeah it's that thanks
what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do with
that yeah that's like that's like saying
like I got me a gift card I got a nipple
piercing in your honor well that's kind
of cool
not really if your girl gets a nipple
piercing of your if you're into that for
your birthday though come on man
you gotta open something up and your
birthday it's like when a girl like gets
like lingerie for your birthday
all right fair fair all right all right
all right all right you're right I mean
I guess tattoos maybe but not a tattoo
of yourself not a mural a mural of you
yeah on her [ __ ] but not a steve-o
ass tattoo yeah yeah you think it wasn't
that style too ahead of it yeah yeah it
says mine forever he's like mine forever
dude that's creepy the silence was
deafening I can only imagine it's like
what sick everyone's like oh my god you
know fake what's it gonna be then you
just hear one someone's like no I
imagine one one girl the back just goes
oh oh
nobody disrespected you you you
disrespected yourself that's crazy man
like literally that's like that's like
all mental illness love that's all
mental illness yeah that's no that's
that's wild that's rough
eight months with somebody and it's not
even that serious you're not even living
together and you're gonna get a tattoo
of his face bro whoa what even is the
maybe he hid a year first like they're
not even in the years of dating okay
now she's gonna spend 80 years with that
on her [ __ ] back I mean doesn't yes
and that I'm assuming this is real which
we should assume because that makes
these fun alright how do you tell her to
take it off
no you I think you just I mean you just
ex communicator I think you just go sir
what other way how could you handle this
you you're not gonna talk to a person
like this reasonably look if she's
willing to go to that extreme in this
case in this scenario I think he just
you just ghost the ghost I think you I
think you hold her hand you know and get
even closer with her yeah you go get
another tattoo yeah you get really close
to her and maybe know what I'd really
love if you do my my face your face what
do you think baby no what I'd love if
you got a one-to-one tattoo of the front
side of my body on the front side of
your body what if this is six-nine is a
girlfriend he's just posting this [ __ ]
from prison we've been together right
for like eight months eight months now
I've been in jail longer than we I think
you hold her hand I think you go to the
tattoo parlor and you look her and I see
I want that [ __ ] off right now
there you go to the doctor you you say
either one of two things but why why
would you want it off like if you're
gonna break up with her mm-hmm but
you're saying you don't want to break up
with her no you break over there yeah
then why wouldn't you want her to have
that oh that's a funny story she [ __ ]
did it
nothing I think you listen there's a
woman out there on this earth right now
that has a giant tattoo of my face with
mine forever written underneath and we
were together for eight months I just
think there's something funny about
going back to the artist and he's like
what's up dude and I'm like that [ __ ]
was trashed dog yeah you didn't get you
didn't get me at all I want you to try
again I want you to do it again do it on
her stomach and do it better because
that back [ __ ] is awful get do it again
bro and like really lean into it be
upset yeah
take part yeah make her be like maybe
this was a bad idea
yeah you get more into it than she's
into yeah yeah yeah okay you go over the
top oh and so maybe she then is like
well he's crazy [ __ ] nuts
you're like oh I love you know we should
do we should do two of my face yeah I
should do one of me happy one of me sad
huh get my dad's face on your back and
then his dad's face [ __ ] you yeah
that's this is what I'm saying fight
fire with fire yeah out crazy yeah you
get the whole you get my whole family on
your back that's what I want to see that
wood now that's a present that's a
present Bambi birthday to me and then
you goes through alright fair enough
fair enough
oh then she walking around with
ancestry.com ad on her back she gotta
walk that one off of the rest of her
life
you